to become psychologically flexible is
more than just addressing personality
it's actually addressing the way we
really relate to ourselves
flexibility is the ability to adjust
your thoughts
actions and feelings to the
circumstances you find yourself in
situations change and so it's important
to be able to adjust
and behave in the most functional way to
achieve your goals
when you're born your brain is not
finished
infant brains are born under
construction
they're waiting for a set of wiring
instructions from the world
if you expose your children to a lot of
varying experiences
then you're basically wiring your
child's brain to function in a flexible
way
and to learn new things when necessary
if your child's experiences are very
restricted
then your child will have less
flexibility to adjust their actions
to the situations that they're in
[Music]
there's a really well-known
demonstration of flexibility called the
stroop test
a sequence of words such as red green
yellow blue
but written in different colors
when you present people with a whole
list of these you find that it takes
people longer to name
the color of the ink when the word is
written in a color that is different
to the actual word the idea behind that
is
in order to be able to name the color
requires people to switch between
different pieces of information in their
mind
in simple terms what happens is that
when they scan the word colour
the automatic processes of reading the
word interfere with the person's ability
to state the color out loud
the more difficult people find this
generally the less cognitively flexible
they are
when your brain can't predict something
or when you have to take in new
information that you didn't predict
that's what we call learning
so your brain can update it can learn
or your brain can ignore the sense data
and just go with its own prediction
flexibility means tailoring a response
to the specific situation
either by predicting well or by learning
when there is prediction error a lot of
what psychological flexibility is about
is the way in which people use resources
that they have available in dealing with
stress
one of the things about psychological
inflexibility is that
people are not using their resources in
a way that's helpful to them
quite often they're using a very narrow
range of their resources to be able to
adapt
and the idea in psychological
flexibility
is really to move people from a state of
what psychologists call languishing of
being stuck in a less than satisfactory
situation
to move them out of that zone into a
zone of achieving more of their
potential
what stops people from changing their
lives from a state of low satisfaction
to one of higher satisfaction
is quite often to do with inflexibility
in the way they approach the problem
that they're facing
so there's a really deep lesson here you
can
take more control over your environment
you are not just a passive recipient of
whatever the world gives you
[Music]
spending time cultivating experiences
and foraging for new information is an
investment
in maintaining a flexible brain
these are all opportunities to expose
yourself to prediction error
so that your brain can solve problems
more flexibly in the future
so exposing yourself to stuff you don't
know
and maybe even ideas you don't like
might make you feel crappy in the moment
but actually it is a
really good investment
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video